Chris Brown decided I've got a love
album the same exact day that mine come
out because you could do I hate it when
guys do this really
hey mr. wonderful here and this is
another episode of ask mr. wonderful now
what I like about this is
no-holds-barred you ask me any question
you want and I give you the answers you
ask I answer now bring them on a mr.
wonderful right now I'm a college
student and I've been getting a lot of
money of through scholarships and I was
wondering what's the best way to start
investing or making money out of that
money like I won't be making like a
hundred grand but I'll be making around
five ten grand
coming through coming out of college so
I was wondering you know medicine stocks
I was looking into account commodities
what's a good way to start making money
and saving up or should I just say bow
thank you
dad fantastic question great time to be
considering it if you're you should save
10 percent of what you're gonna make if
you're making five thousand five hundred
dollars and invest it in a basket of
stocks like an ETF there's so many
conservative ETFs out there I like
dividend-paying conservative ETFs I'm
not going to recommend a ticker but but
the concept of just using a single ETF
that maybe have 20 30 50 stocks in it is
the best way to do it and then
consistently maintain putting into this
every month or two months whenever you
can the 10% of your salary by that's if
you do that and even only have an
average salary of 52 thousand dollars
and you do it until you're 65 you'll end
up with a couple of million dollars in
the bank that's the greatest strategy
the fact that you're thinking about it
is fantastic good luck to you I'd stay
focused on saving and investing stocks
are terrific over a long period of time
yes there is volatility but you'll be
buying some when the stocks go down
you'll be buying some as they go up over
the long period of time you're gonna
make six or seven percent that's what
the market has provided over the last 50
years mr. wonderful thank you so much
for your willingness to take this
question really do appreciate that my
name is Ron and I own a media company
which is essentially a
websites and business is pretty good
things are going pretty well
but looking back at your history my
question is what is it that you feel if
you could point to one particular thing
that you did with soft key software
solutions what is it that you did to
bring it from pretty good to great what
is it that made that company you know a
7 out of 10
to a 10 out of 10 that increased your
profits increase your size I'm trying to
figure out how to go to that next level
even though I'm doing pretty well
we're on that's a great question how do
you get to the next level you hire
amazing people and you give them a piece
of the upside very hard to do in a
services businesses like yours but not
impossible scale is everything you want
to get bigger the only way you're gonna
do that is expand beyond being just a
one-man show and that's tough finding
the right partners that should augment
your skills you know if you're great in
one thing like sales and marketing get
someone who's better in logistics or
hiring people that can actually do more
of these websites I've always found in
every one of my deals that maybe money
it's the team I built a fantastic team
of people working together towards a
single mission the better the people and
more money I made it's that simple but I
always gave up some to them so they were
part of the story and I always found
even if I gave up half which I did in
the case of The Learning Company that
outcome was four point two billion
dollars so I was pretty happy with the
outcome in the long run it's all about
team it's really hard to do it on your
own and building a team you have to
build it slowly and find the right
partners and then give them some of the
upside that's my answer
[Music]
hello mr. wonderful hope all is
wonderful with you here is my question
I find that my biggest weakness in my
life is I'm too emotional about
everything so I ask you in your life
growing up did you find yourself in
situations where you got angry or you
got mad or you didn't agree with
somebody when you knew that you were
right and how do you deal with your
emotions I'm curious to know Richard
what a fantastic question you're
absolutely right your emotions can be
your best friend but also your your
worst enemy because when you make a
rational decisions that are based on
sheer emotion you're often making the
wrong decision and yet emotions are part
of your intuitive gut feel you have to
understand them and I find the best way
to do it is don't be impulsive I get
pissed off too I get angry I get elation
I get all of those things too but what
I've learned over time is not to make
decisions under the influence of any of
those emotions just delay the decision
until you can be rational maybe sleep on
it get up in the morning have a coffee
and think about it and if you're not
comfortable yet don't make the decision
there's always the option to do nothing
for a while and what the only way you're
going to learn that's to experience all
the decisions I made under heavy duress
or emotional stress have cost me a
fortune big mistakes and also you know
revenge is a stupid emotion it makes you
do stupid things be rational about it
doesn't mean you can't you know be
pragmatic but being motivated by hatred
or fear or anything like that is never a
good outcome you know in life [ __ ]
happens
got a deal with it but you have to do it
rationally and pragmatically don't get
caught up in emotion simply wait it out
hello and thanks for your time Jeff
wonderful
I only have a minute in my ingredients
list it's a bit ugly so I will just jump
in and hope you can spin this into a
meal as a person who invests in
purchases and sells businesses from the
other side of the table that I am on I
am curious as to know how you would
handle this if you were starting all
over again I created an electronic
device and complementing desktop
software the mobile app to follow and
finding interested parties to fund the
first production run has been difficult
I have gotten a few offers where they
mostly offered me little money and
wanted to make me an employee of my own
creation one person in this group
offered me a generous deal but as
laid-back as they are about money they
do have a record and say and do pretty
questionable things would you take the
money from a questionable and publicly
unpredictable person Ana
pay me back whenever tip with a flat
one-time fee in no window take
substantially less from a respected
business person who was trying to
lowball you just so you can get off the
ground and involved with people who are
classically respected or you just keep
waiting and hope you don't run ashore
Anthony fantastic options I would go
with the person I respected that was
low-balling you I would try and move
them up a little bit what you need is to
get this thing off the ground to prove
it out I mean you know having a little
bit of something that works versus
nothing of something never got off the
ground those are obvious decisions you
want to work with somebody respect and
you trust not somebody who thinks a
slime ball let's face it
it's not worth it life's too short go
with the person that's lowball and you
ask for a little bit more but get the
deal done I mean get something going
that's that's what being an entrepreneur
is all about you never get what you want
I don't get what I want you have to
compromise but the do nothing in this
case is a bad decision because you won't
get anything in that case good luck I'm
mr. wonderful I was wanting to clarify
what is the best way for Millennials to
be able to pay off their student loans
if you could verify this how to really
appreciate it thank you for your time
have a great day John the best way for
Millennials to pay off their student
loans is get myopically focused on it
even while you're in school get a job
slinging beer or waiting tables that's
what I did I hate student debt I hate
being in debt everything in my power was
to take as much as my part-time jobs
even even after I
out of college and pay back any loans I
had I owed money all over the place
you're not free until you get out of
debt and you can't save anything while
you're paying back interest and often
people buy a lot of crap they don't need
so rule number one is don't buy crap you
don't need 15 pairs of jeans you need to
you don't need 20 pairs of shoes you
need to you need a good suit you need a
tie sometimes you're gonna need that but
don't buy a bunch of crap you don't need
take it and put every dime you can
towards that suit alone you can pay it
off in about 36 months I find if you're
really focused assuming you have a job
you don't get a full-time job as a
part-time try and make 20% of what you
earn off against that loan those loans
are nasty interest rates go up over time
and you eat up so much of your potential
by paying interest to somebody else pay
it off
hey mr. wonderful is mrs. fabulous and I
have a question that only you can answer
okay for a Rolex currently the case back
isn't clear where you can see the
movement do you think it would be tacky
in any way to switch that case back to a
clear sapphire glass so you can actually
see the movement
mrs. fabulous you've come to the right
place I'm glad you asked me this
question you cannot touch that Rolex you
cannot modify it you can't drill it you
can't put diamonds in it a Rolex has a
protocol in terms of its value in the
market and you know I'm wearing one
right now and let's have a look at the
back if this is a very valuable Rolex
very hard to get I mean this is an
extraordinary you know I mean that the
thing is you can't mess with the back
you have no I've changed the bracelet to
red everybody knows I do that but I have
the original bracelet in its case and
all the papers but to get a GMT like
this you might wait a year or two years
I don't know but the point is if you
were to change this back you would be
tampering with the integrity and the
essence of the watch its sole
effectively now people do this but they
trash the value of the watch it's
something else I want to tell you when
you get a collectible watch like this
and most Rolexes are and you take it in
for a cleaning
where they do on an official basis
remove the back clean it make sure it's
all functioning ask them to make sure
they do not polish the watch never touch
the patina the scratches of the watch
never touch it at all because that is
part of the sole of the watch as well
when they polish it to make it shiny
again they were moving several microns
of metal which is a just a faux pas a
huge mistake so if you're if you're
understanding the value of a Rolex and
it's collectability over the lifetime
you have it do not mess with it do not
take the back off do not replace it live
with it exactly the way it is this watch
has gone up in value dramatically since
I bought it and I'm not messing with it
I would never polish it boy it looks
good on me these red bands look
spectacular on me
[Music]